the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
what we're going to talk about today's
is a continuation of last time I want to
review Newton's method because I want to
talk to you about its accuracy okay so
if you remember the way Newton's method
works is this if you have a curve and
you want to know where whether it
crosses the axis and you don't know
where this point is this point which
I'll call X here what you do is you take
a guess maybe you take a point X 0 here
and then you go down to this point on
the graph and you draw the tangent line
I'll draw these in a couple of different
colors so that you can see the
difference between them so here's a
tangent line it's coming out like that
all right and that one is going to get a
little closer to the to our target point
but now the trick is and this is rather
hard to see because the scale gets small
incredibly fast is that if you go right
up from that and you do this same trick
over again that is this is your second
guess x1 and now you draw the second
tangent line which is going to come down
this way that's really close you can see
here on the chalkboard it's practically
the same as the dot of X so that's the
next guess which is x2 and I want to
analyze now how close it gets and just
describe to you to how it works so let
me just remind you of the formulas to
it's it's worth having them in your head
so the formula for the next one is is
this and then the idea is to just to
repeat this process which has a fancy
name which is 2 in algorithms which is
to iterate if you like so we repeat the
process and that means for example
generate x2 from x1 by the same formula
and we did this last time and more
generally the n plus first is generated
from the nth guess by this formula here
all right so what I'd like to do is just
draw the picture of one step a little
bit more closely so I want to blow up
the picture which is which is above me
there whoops that's a little too high
where my braces okay got to get it a
little lower than that since I'm going
to depict everything above the line here
so here's my curve coming down and
suppose that x1 is here so this is
directly above it as this point here and
then as I drew it this green tangent
it's coming down like that it's a little
bit closer and this was the place x2 and
then here was was X our target which is
where the curve crosses is opposed to
the straight
tangent line crossing okay so that's the
picture that I want you to keep in mind
and now we're just going to do a very
qualitative kind of error analysis so
here's our error analysis and we're
starting out the distance between X 1
and X is what we want to measure in
other words how close we are to where
where we're heading and so I've called
that I'm going to call that error 1
that's X minus x1 in absolute value and
then e2 would be X minus x2 and absolute
value and so forth and last time when I
was estimating the size of this so en
would be whatever it was last time
remember we did it
for specific case so last time I
actually wrote down the numbers and they
were these numbers maybe you could call
them en which was the absolute value of
square root of 5 minus xn this these
were the sizes that I was writing down
last time and I just want to talk about
in general what to expect that worked
amazingly well and I want to show you
that that's true pretty much in general
so the first distance again this a 1 is
is this distance here that's the e 1 and
then this shorter distance here this
little bit which I'll mark maybe in
green is is is e - so how much shorter
is e 1 and E 2 well the idea is pretty
simple it's that if this distance and
this vertical distance they're probably
about the same as the same as the
perpendicular distance and this is
basically the situation of a curve
touching a tangent line then the
separation is going to be quadratic and
that's basically what's going to happen
so in other words the distance e 2 is
going to be about the square of the
distance d1 and that's really the only
feature of this that I want to point out
so approximately this is the situation
that we're going to get and so what that
means is and maybe thinking from last
time what we had was was something
roughly like this you have an e 0 you
have an e 1 you have an e 2 you have an
e 3 and so forth and yell write down e 4
here and last time this was about 10 to
the minus 1 so the expectation based on
this rule is that the next error is the
square of the previous one so that's 10
to the minus 2 the next one is the
square of the previous one so that's 10
to the minus 4 and the next one is the
square of that that's 10 to the minus 8
and this one is 10 to the minus 16 okay
so the thing that's impressive about
this list of numbers is you can see that
the number of digits
of accuracy doubles at each stage
accuracy doubles at each step all right
the number of digits of accuracy doubles
at each step so very very quickly you
get past the accuracy of your calculator
as you saw on your problem set and this
thing works beautifully so so let me
just summarize by saying that Newton's
method works very well by which I mean
this this this kind of rate and and I
want to be just slightly specific if
they're really two conditions disguised
in this that are going on one is that F
prime has to be not to be to be not
small okay and F double Prime has to be
not too big all right
that's roughly speaking what's going on
I'll explain these in just a second and
X zero starts nearby nearby the the
target value X all right so that's
really what's what's going on here and
so let me just illustrate to you so I'm
not going to explain this except to say
the reason why the second derivative
gets involved is that it's how curved
the curve is that's how far away we get
if it the second derivative was 0 that
would be the best possible case then we
would get it on the nose if it's not -
if the second derivative at leeds the
quadratic part is not too big so we
don't get away very far from the green
line to the to the curve itself
the other thing to say is as I said that
that that x0 needs to start nearby so
I'll explain that by explaining what
what maybe could go wrong so so they're
the ways the method can fail and one
example which actually would have
happened in our in our example from last
time which was which was y equals x
squared minus 5 is suppose we'd started
x0 over here okay then this thing would
have gone off to the left and we would
have landed on the not the square root
of 5 but the other root so if it's too
far away then we get the wrong route all
right so that's an example explaining
that the X here needs to start near the
the root that we're in talking about
otherwise the the method doesn't know
which root you're asking for it only
knows where you started so it may go off
to the wrong place okay it's not a it's
not a it can't read your mind yes
question
oh good question so the other the
question was what if the first error is
larger than one are you in trouble and
the answer is absolutely yes if you have
quadratic behavior you can see if you
have a quadratic nearby it's pretty
close to the straight line but far away
a parabola is miles from a straight line
it's way way way far away so if you're
foolish enough to start you know over
here you may have some trouble making
progress actually it it it isn't when I
that littlewiggle they're just meant
proportional to in fact in the
particular case of a parabola it manages
to get back it saves itself but there's
no guarantee of that sort of thing you
really do want to start reasonably close
yeah
you know what you have to do is you have
to watch out that is you you there it's
hard to know what assumptions to make
about x0 you you plug it into the
machine and you see what you get and
either it works or it doesn't you can
tell that it's marching toward a
specific place and you can tell that
that place probably is a zero usually
but maybe it's not the one you were
looking for so in other words you have
to use your head you run the program and
then you see what it does alright and if
you're lucky the problem is if you have
no idea where the zero is you may just
wander around forever
as we'll see in a second ok so the next
example here is the following I said
that F prime has to be not too small
there's a real catastrophe hiding just
inside this picture which is the
transition between when you find the
positive root when you find the negative
root here which is if you're right down
here you if you were foolish enough to
get 0 then what's going to happen is
you're tangent line is horizontal it
doesn't even meet the axis so in the
formula you can see that's a catastrophe
because there's an F Prime in the
denominator all right so that's 0 that's
undefined
it's not surprising it's consistent the
parallel line doesn't meet the axis and
you have no x1 so you had so if you like
another point here is is that F prime 0
is a disaster a disaster for this for
the method because the next so say if f
of X 0 is is 0 then then x1 is undefined
and finally there's there's one other
weird thing that can happen which is
which I'll just draw a picture of
schematically which you can get from a
wiggle all right so this wiggle has
three roots the way I've drawn it
and it can be that you can start over
here with your x0 and draw your tangent
line and go over here to annex one and
then that tangent line will take you
right back to the x0 all right I didn't
draw it quite right but it's yeah that's
about right so it goes over like this so
let me draw the two tangent lines so
that you can see it properly sorry I
messed it up so here are the two tangent
lines this guy and this guy and it just
goes back and forth x0 cycles to x1 and
x1 goes back to x0 we have a cycle and
it never goes anywhere this is you know
the grass is always greener it's over
here it thinks oh I really would prefer
to go to this 0 and then it thinks oh I
want to go back and it goes back and
forth and back and forth grass is always
greener on the other side of the fence
never never gets anywhere okay so those
are the sorts of things that can go
wrong with Newton's method nevertheless
it's fantastic it works very well and in
a lot of situations and solves basically
any equation that you can imagine
numerically all right now next we're
going to move on we're going to move on
to something which is a little
theoretical which is the mean value
theorem and that will allow us in a just
a day or so to launch into the ideas of
integration which is the whole second
half of the course so let's get started
with that
the mean value theorem will henceforth
the abbreviated mvt so I don't have to
write quite as much every time I refer
to it the mean value theorem
colloquially says the following if you
go from Boston to LA which I think a lot
of Red Sox fans are going to want to do
soon so that's three thousand miles in
six hours then at some time you are
going at a certain speed the average of
this speed average so speed which in
this case is what so we're going at the
average speed that's 3,000 miles times
six hours so that's 500 miles per hour
exactly so some time on your journey of
course some of the time you were going
more than 500 miles an hour's some times
you were going less and some time you
must have been going 500 miles an hour
exactly that's the mean value theorem
the reason why it's called mean value
theorem is that word mean is the same as
the word average
all right so now I'm going to state it
in math symbols the same theorem and
it's a formula it says that the
difference quotient so this is the
distance traveled divided by the time
elapsed that's the average speed is
equal to the infinitesimally speed for
some some time in between so some C
which is in between a and B I'm not
quite done it's a real theorem it has
hypotheses I've told you the conclusion
first but there are some hypotheses
they're straightforward hypotheses
provided F is differentiable that is it
has a different derivative in the
interval a less than X less than B and
continuous in a less than or equal to X
less than or equal to B there has to be
a sense that you can make out of the
speed or the rate of change of F at each
intermediate point and in order for the
values at the ends to make sense it has
to be continuous there has to be a link
between the values at the ends and of
what's going on in between if it were
discontinuous there would be no relation
between the left and right values and
the rest of the function all right so
here's the theorem conclusion that's
high
áthis and it means what I said more
colloquially up above
now I'm going to prove this theorem
immediately at least give a geometric
intuitive argument which is not very
different from the one that's given you
know in a very systematic treatment so
here's the proof of the mean value
theorem it's really just a picture so
here's a place and here's another place
on the graph and the graph is going
along like this let's say and this line
here is the secant line so this is a
comma f of a down here and this is B
comma F of B up there and this segment
is the secant and it's slope is the
slope that we're aiming for the slope of
that line is the left-hand side of this
formula here so we need to find
something with that slope and what we
need to find is a tangent line with that
slope because this is what's on the
right-hand side is a slope of a tangent
line so here's how we construct it we
take a parallel line down here and then
we just translate it up leaving it
parallel we move it up towards this one
until it touches and where it touches at
this point of tangency down there I've
just found my value of C and you can see
that if the tangent line is parallel to
this line that's exactly the equation
that we want so this thing has slope F
prime of C and this other one has slope
a slope equal to this complicated
expression f of B minus F of a divided
by B minus a
that is almost the end of the proof
there's one problem so again we move a
parallel line up move up a parallel line
until it touches there's a little
subtlety here which I just want to
emphasize which is that that dotted line
keeps on going here but when we bring it
up we're going to ignore what's
happening outside of a and beyond B all
right so we're just going to ignore the
rest of the graph but there is one thing
that can go wrong so if it does not
touch then the picture looks like this
here are the same two points and the
graph is all above and we brought up our
thing and it went like that okay so we
didn't we didn't construct a tangent
line
if this happens right so we're in
trouble in that point in this situation
sorry all right
but there's a trick which is a
straightforward trick then bring bring
other tangent lines down from the top so
parallel lines sorry not tangent lines
parallel lines from above
all right so so that's that's the whole
story
that's how we cook up this point see
with the right properties well I want to
point out just one more theoretical
thing and then the rest we're going to
be drawing conclusions so there's one
more theoretical remark about the proof
which is something that is is fairly
important to understand when you
understand a proof you should always be
thinking about why the hypotheses are
necessary where did I use the hypothesis
and I want to give you an example where
the proof doesn't work to show you that
the hypothesis is an important one so
the example is the following I'll just
take a function which is to two straight
lines like this and if you try to
perform this trick with these things
then it's going to come up and it's
going to touch here but the problem is
that the tangent line is not defined
here there are lots of tangents and
there's no derivative at this point so
the derivative doesn't exist here all
right so that this is the claim that one
bad point ruins the proof we need F
prime to exist
at all so f prime of X to exist at all X
in between can't get away even with one
defective point ok so now it's time to
draw some consequences and the main
consequence is going to be have to do
with applications to graphing but we'll
see tomorrow and for the rest of the
course that this is this is even more
significant it's it's significant to all
the rest of calculus I'm going to list
three consequences which you're quite
familiar with already so the first one
is if f prime is positive then F is
increasing and the second one is if F
prime is negative then F is decreasing
and the last one seems like the simplest
but even this one alone is the key to
everything if F prime is zero then F is
constant
these are three consequences now of the
of the mean value theorem and let me
show you how they're proved I just told
you that they were true maybe a while
ago and certainly I mentioned the first
two the the last one was so simple that
we maybe just swept it under the rug you
did use it on a problem set once or
twice but it turns out that this
actually requires proof and we're going
to give the purple right now now the the
way that the proof goes is simply to
write down to rewrite star rewrite our
formula which says that F of B minus F
of a over B minus a is equal to F prime
of C and you see I've written it from
left to right here to say that the right
hand side information about the
derivative is going to be giving the
information about the function that's
the way I'm going to read it in order to
express this though I'm going to just
rewrite it a couple of times here so
here's F of a multiplying through by the
denominator and now I'm going to write
it in another customary form for the
mean value theorem which is f of B is
equal to F of a plus F prime of C times
B minus a right so here's another
version I should probably have put this
one in a box to begin with anyway and
just changing it around algebraically
it's this fact here they're the same
thing
and now with the formula written in this
form I claim that I can check these
three facts so let's start with the
first one I'm going to set things up
always so that a is less than B and
that's the set up of the the theorem and
so that means that B minus a is positive
all right which means that this factor
over here is positive number if F prime
is positive then which is what happens
in the first case that's the assumption
that we're making then this is a
positive number and so f of B is more
than F of a which means that it's
increasing it goes up as the value goes
up
similarly if F prime of C is negative
then this is a positive times a negative
number this is negative it's an F of B
is less than F of a so it goes the other
way so maybe I'll write it this way and
finally if F prime of C is zero then F
of B is equal to F of a which if you
apply to all possible ends means if you
can do it for every interval which you
can then that means that F is constant
it's never gets to change values
well you might have believed these these
facts already but I just want to
emphasize to you that this turns out to
be the the one key link between
infinitesimals between limits and these
actual differences before we were saying
that the difference quotient was
approximately equal to a derivative now
we're saying that it's exactly equal to
a derivative although we don't know
exactly which point to use it's some
point in between all right I'm going to
be deducing some other consequences in a
second but I don't want to stop for a
second to make sure that everybody's on
board especially since I finished the
blackboards here before we everybody
happy one one question
I'm just in a repeated question first
I'm a little bit confused you said about
what guarantees that there's a point of
tangency that's that's what you said
okay so do you want to elaborate or do
you or you want to stop with that what
you just said I mean what is it that
confuses you about it yeah
so so I'm not claiming that there's only
one point this could wiggle a lot of
times and it maybe touches at 10 places
in other words it's okay with me if it
touches more than once then I just have
more the more the merrier in other words
I don't I'm not I don't want there
necessarily only to be one it could come
down like this and touch a second time
all right
is that what was concerning you yeah so
so in mathematics one when we claim that
this is true for some point we don't
necessarily mean that it doesn't work
for others in fact if the function is
constant this is zero and in fact this
equation is true for every C so that
satisfies your question okay all right
it's it's a it whether this the fact
that this point exists is actually is a
touchy point I just convinced you of it
visually it's a geometric issue whether
you're allowed to do this indeed it has
to do with the existence of tangent
lines and more analysis than we can do
in this class yeah another question
pardon me the the question is what's the
difference between this and the linear
approximation and I think so let me let
me see if I can I can describe that I'll
leave the theorem on the board I'm going
to get rid of the colloquial version of
the theorem
and I'll try to describe to you the
difference between this and the linear
approximation I was planning to do that
in a while but I will do it right now
since that's what you're asking that's
fine
so the here's here's a situation the
linear approximation so let's say
comparison with linear approximation
they're very closely related the linear
approximation says the change in F over
the change in X that's the left hand
side of this thing is approximately F
prime of a for B near near a and B minus
a is equal to Delta X all right this
statement which is in the box which is
sitting right up there is the statement
that this change in in F is actually
equal to something not approximately
equal to it it's equal to F prime of
some C and the problem here is that we
don't know exactly which seat this is
for some C between a and and B all right
so that's the difference between the two
and let me
elaborate a little bit if you're trying
to understand what F of B minus F of a
divided by B minus a is the mean value
theorem is telling you for sure that
it's equal to this F prime of C so that
means it's less than or equal to the
largest possible value on the largest
value you can get for sure and this is
on the whole interval and I'm going to
include the ends because when you take a
max it's sometimes achieved at the ends
and similarly because it's F prime of C
it's definitely bigger than the min on
this same interval here this is all you
can say based on the mean value theorem
all you know is this and colloquially
what that means is that the average
speed is between the maximum and the
minimum not very surprising all right
mean value theorem is supposed to be
very intuitively obvious it's saying the
average speed is trapped between the
maximum speed and the minimum speed for
sure that's something and that's why
incidentally you know this wasn't really
proved when newton and leibniz were
around but let's write this so that you
can read it average speed is between the
max and then and but nobody had any
trouble they didn't they didn't
disbelieve it because it's it's a very
natural thing now
if for example I take any kind of linear
approximation say for instance each of
the X is approximately 1 plus X then I'm
making the guess now no I don't want to
say this yet that's that's not going to
explain it to you well enough what we're
saying so this is this is the mean value
theorem this is what the mean value
theorem says and here is the linear
approximation the linear approximation
is saying that the average speed is
approximately the initial speed or
possibly the final speed so if a is the
left endpoint then it's the initial
speed if it happens to be the right
endpoint if the value of X is to the
left then it's the final speed so those
are the so you can see it's
approximately right because the speed
when you're on a short interval
shouldn't be varying very much the
maximum n should be pretty close
together so and that's why the linear
approximation is reasonable and this is
telling you absolutely it's no less than
the men and no more than the max yeah
little king if you approach from the top
so that if it's still under here I can
show you it again oh yeah still there
good oh the one with the with the wiggle
on top yeah this one you can't because
there's nothing to touch and it also
fails from the bottom because there's
this bad point from the top yeah it
could work it can certainly worth both
ways so for example see if you're a
machine you you you maybe don't have a
way of doing this but if you're a human
being you can spot all the places right
there are a bunch of spots where the
slope is right and it's perfectly okay
all of them work it's not that the sea
is the same it's just we've now found
one two three four five seas for which
it works if you're asked to find a sea
so first of all that's a kind of a phony
question okay those are there's some
questions on your problem set which ask
you to find a sea that actually is
struggling to get you to understand what
the statement of the mean value theorem
is but you should you should not pay a
whole lot of attention to those
questions they're not very impressive
but of course you would have to find all
the place you could if it asks you to
find one you find one if you if you can
find some more fine you can pick
whichever one you want mean value
theorem just doesn't doesn't care the
mean value theorem doesn't care because
actually the mean value theorem is never
used except two in real life except in
this context here you can never nail
down which sea it is so the only thing
you can say is that you're going slower
than the maximum speed and faster than
the minimum speed sorry say it again
if you're asked for a specific C you
have to take it you have to find a
specific C and it has to be in the range
in between it has to be in here all
right
okay so now I want to I want to tell you
about another kind of application which
is really just a consequence of what
I've described here III should have
emphasized by the way this probably I I
was I I should be doing this
I guess we've never used this color here
it's popular this is pink so this one is
so good so since we're going to do this
all right
so the reason why I'm the explanation
exclamation points are temporary this is
such an obvious fact but but this is the
way that you're going to want to use the
mean value theorem and this is the only
way you need to understand the mean
value theorem on your test or ever in
your whole life okay so this is this is
the way it will be used as I will make
very clear when we review for the exam
now in practice what happens is you even
forget about the mean value theorem and
what you remember is these three
properties here which are themselves
consequences of the mean value theorem
so these are the ones that I want to
illustrate now in my next discussion
here these are I'm just going to talk
about inequalities inequalities are
relationships between functions and I'm
going to prove a couple of them using
the properties over there the properties
that functions with positive derivatives
are increasing here's an example e to
the X is greater than one plus X for X
greater than zero
the proof is the following
I consider so here's a proof I consider
the function f of X which is the
difference to the X minus 1 plus X I
observe that it starts at f of 0 equal
to well that's e to the 0 minus 1 plus 0
which is 0
and it keeps on going f prime of X is e
to the X if I differentiate here the 1
goes away I get minus 1 that's the
derivative of the function and this
function because e to the X is bigger
than 1 for X positive is positive for X
positive as X gets bigger and bigger
this rate of increase is positive and
therefore 3 dots that's therefore f of X
is bigger than its starting place for X
bigger than 0 if it's increasing then
that's in particular its increasing
starting from 0 so this is true now all
I have to do is read what this
inequality says now what it says is that
e to the X just plug in for f of X which
is right here minus 1 plus X is greater
than the starting value which was 0 and
now I put the the thing that's negative
on the other side so that's the same
thing as e to the X is bigger than 1
plus X that's of typical inequality and
now we'll use this principle again
oh gee I erase the wrong thing I erased
the statement and not the proof well
hide the proof and the next thing I want
to prove to you is that e to the X is
bigger than 1 plus X plus x squared over
2 so how do I do that I introduce a
function G of X which is e to the X
minus this and now I'm going to just
going to do exactly the same thing I did
before which is I get started with G of
0 which is 1 minus 1 which is 0 and G
prime of X is e to the X minus now look
at what happens when I differentiate
this the 1 goes away the X gives me a 1
and the x squared over 2 gives me a plus
X and this one is positive for X greater
than 0 because of step 1 because of the
previous one that I did all right so
this one is increasing G is increasing
which says that G of X is bigger than G
of 0 and if you just read that off it's
exactly the same as our inequality e to
the X bigger than 1 plus X plus x
squared over 2
now you can keep on going with this
essentially forever and let me just
write down what you get you get e to the
X is greater than 1 plus X plus x
squared over 2 the next one turns out to
be X cubed over 3 times 2 X to the 4th
over 4 times 3 times 2 and you can do
whatever you want you can do others and
this is like The Tortoise and the hare
all right this is the tortoise and this
is the hare it's always ahead but
eventually if you go infinitely far it
catches up so this is the the act turns
out to be exactly equal to e to the X in
the limit and we'll talk about that
maybe at the end of the course